hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
just checking to see how your work week
is going
you know you're out there you put your
pants on one leg at a [ __ ] time
oh jesus speaking of which i got to go
to work today
you know sorry for the frogginess my
voice i just i woke up yeah i literally
just woke up and i was just like i got
to go do my podcast
you know went right to work
did i get some cereal no
did i have an english muffin no what did
i do i [ __ ]
turned off the outside lights walked out
to my
garage my gay raj i put the gay in gay
raj
and uh just went right to work
you know
it's the kind of guy i am
anybody can come downstairs you know
read a newspaper does that even [ __ ]
exist anymore i actually saw a guy
yesterday at the gym
riding an exercise bicycle
while reading the sports page
like a newspaper i was like wow that guy
is [ __ ]
he's going old school i will tell you it
does bother me when i see people like uh
you know
when they're on like a [ __ ]
elliptical
and they're going like really slow or
they're walking slow or they're riding
the exercise bike slow and they're just
staring at their phone
it just drives me at the [ __ ] wall
because i know they're just like you
know i can't lose i just can't lose i go
to the gym
i do cardio every day now you don't
you don't
i mean you're doing more than just
sitting there i will give you that
my god can we get into pet peeves at the
gym
how about the [ __ ] that does cardio
first gets [ __ ]
dripping wet sweaty then goes over to
the stretching area lays down on the
[ __ ] floor stretches out doesn't even
wipe it up
[ __ ] unreal
you know i remember years ago
i stopped going to the gym
and uh where i lived in my last house i
put like a little mini gym in there
and of course the first day is when i
[ __ ] up my my rotator cuff i'd already
[ __ ] it up and didn't realize
and i put like uh the 45 145 on each
side 135 pounds do a little warm-up set
knock out 10.
see if i can still put up a buck 80 for
four right
brought it down one time [ __ ] my whole
shoulder up but the reason why i made
um
the reason i made that little uh gymnast
because i got grossed out going to the
gym just thinking like this is just uh
it's just a bunch of sweaty people
sweating all over a bunch of [ __ ] you
know and i know you got the little
bottles here
you spray it
do whatever makes you feel better
i don't know i just got all [ __ ]
grossed out
here's another one i saw a guy benching
at the squat rack
[ __ ] annoying
what about the woman that does the bent
over rose on like the uh
the bench at the bench station
it's like no no no they don't
you can't [ __ ] do that everybody
wants that thing and you need at the
very least if you're gonna go over there
you could be doing the bench press
instead of another exercise that's
taking up the bench press station
um
another one you're doing lat pull downs
one of those lat [ __ ] rose station
giant things and then there's a pull-up
bar
and some dad bod guy comes over there
and he starts doing [ __ ] pull-ups and
he's so [ __ ] fat like the entire
[ __ ] thing is rocking back and forth
like you're on an old swing set
and you're in the middle of your set
trying to get your reps in
down one two
you know up one two down one two three
four down one two explode
down and don't forget the negative right
four three two one one two four three
two one
um
that's just some little things
just some little things what about when
the [ __ ] guy uh
some guy's doing like pyramids and he
needs like dumbbells
and he grabs one of like 19 different
weights and you go over there and
there's like nothing
you [ __ ] standing there looking
around for rick allen did rick allen
just joined the gym i thought def
leppard was on tour where the [ __ ] can i
have one pair of [ __ ] dumbbells here
and it's always the ones that everybody
uses right
20 25s and 30s like you know those are
probably the most pop maybe 15s to 25s
you get up to like 30 pounds doing curls
when you're my age it's just like what
am i trying to prove here
that i'm still dumb enough to hurt
myself and try to lift too much weight
30 pounds it's just
you know this this i mean i'm all
natural people you get to be 54 years
old 30 pounds it's just like jesus
you know
what am i carrying a fat person across
the threshold over here
um
remember that was like a thing you had
to [ __ ] do did you ever even have to
do it or did you just somebody do it in
the movies in hollywood and everybody
felt like they had to do it you got to
carry your wife across the [ __ ]
because she's finally going to bang you
so you got to pick her fat ass up right
you got to walk her across the threshold
it's just like what are we
just the whole beginning of that
all right get used to it buddy
this is the amount of work you're gonna
have to get in you're gonna have to put
in
so both of you can experience pleasure
she's just gonna [ __ ] lay there
oh bill what is going on i don't know i
just have a ton of [ __ ] work to do
today i don't want to i'm just being an
[ __ ] um i gotta knock out this next
pass of the movie
we turning in it's uh
uh the movie is gonna be [ __ ] really
good i'm i'm talking [ __ ] early i'm not
talking [ __ ] i'm just i'm just stating
facts it's gonna be really [ __ ] good
i have the movie trailer
ready to go
and um
yeah i'm [ __ ] psyched
it's it's becoming fun to go into the
edit room because everything is working
and just doing a little
you know nip and tuck here or there so
uh very excited so pretty soon we're
gonna have the picture locked and then
we're gonna score it meaning we're gonna
have the music and then they're gonna
colorize it
so uh everything looks nice
and uh then i think it's i think it's
done
i have no idea
you know my daughter right she's got
this thing now she's just like dad i
want you to sleep with me i don't like
sleeping alone on all this type of stuff
i'm like well dad sleeps with mom i
can't
she goes just one night can you just
come in like one night or whatever
so i was like all right tomorrow night
i'll do it
and she's all upset and i go listen you
gotta understand something all right i
go i love you do you understand that i
go you you are literally the greatest
thing that ever happened to me and i'm
so proud you're my daughter
you know what she said
she said dad
can you buy me a batman costume for
halloween
[Laughter]
that was her response
and i [ __ ] died laughing
and then that became the bit i was like
stop asking me for stuff when i'm saying
nice things for you
i'm saying nice things to you and then
she immediately smiled and then i just
started saying all this lovey-dovey
stuff to her and she just
you know can you get me minecraft
she's obsessed with that because every
kid i guess is out there playing
minecraft
it's like no you're not getting video
games starts off nice you build a video
uh village and then you got to start
killing people the next thing you know
you're playing people online and that's
where all the pedophiles are no
it's not happening
anything else is [ __ ] cool
goddamn [ __ ]
stupid ass [ __ ] internet it's it's
just really like the amount of [ __ ]
i swear to god that they just don't give
a [ __ ] about
um
i really think i don't know this is
[ __ ] i don't know if this is crazy
but to come right off the heels of uh
considering you know they've taken
abortion away in so many of these states
uh can we just like start killing sex
offenders
pedophiles and all that you're not gonna
cure it
so that's it it's like oh you did what
to who okay that's it
that's it
no
um
[ __ ] red sox lost again
did i already talk about this i've
started this podcast twice i can't
remember
[ __ ] lost again [ __ ] lost a gun
that could not hold a goddamn lead it
was nice to see bobby darbat go yard
[ __ ] twice
dude i'm telling you that big [ __ ] man
he gets a hold of one
it's going all the way out to [ __ ]
kenmore square
um
i don't know everybody's like [ __ ]
on the red sox when they suck it's like
what the [ __ ] you talking that all their
starters are hurt
dude they [ __ ] they [ __ ] suck dude
our best [ __ ] player is you know
bobby dobeck's playing third devers is
out our whole [ __ ] starting rotation
is out
yes we're gonna have a tough time at the
major league level
that's why i think it's [ __ ] you
know if the red sox starters you know
are the third team in major league
baseball to to go a month without
getting a win i mean
it's a pretty easy thing to do when
[ __ ] all your starters are out i'm
just saying all right i don't want to
get crazy here
hey i'm coming around to the guardians
took a second really didn't like the
name then i'm like yeah it
kind of sounds heroic
cleveland guardians
it does sound a little federal reserve
type of thing you know like it's some
sort of freemason [ __ ]
i no it's just a gargoyle hey what's
that little hand signal he's doing you
know
those dumb groups those secret societies
[Laughter]
what if anybody in a secret society
right he's just standing there wearing
your stupid
hooded robe
to everybody to do something [ __ ]
some sort of
sacrifice to a farm animal
before you know just some
so y'all don't feel like animals for
having a big [ __ ] orgy
i wonder if anybody ever just looks one
secret society member looks over another
one just being like
it's pretty stupid isn't it
like what are we doing
why am i walking around in this
this [ __ ] rope
oh man i remember seeing that like a
cult why are [ __ ] cults they're
always big on these like that gives them
like credibility like for for morons i
swear to god if they join a group and
there's some sort of robe
involved in a ceremony
oh my god and then if people stand in a
circle forget it it's over
we'll follow you to central america and
drink the kool-aid
what the [ __ ] was that guy's name
jonestown
not bobby jones he played for the 76ers
bobby jonestown was in the spectrum
dude that guy i swear to god he looked
like he managed a country band and he
was stealing money from him these
[ __ ] people
followed this guy
down to central america and they all
[ __ ]
when the feds were closing in
the ultimate narcissist every i'm gonna
go to jail so i don't want to go to jail
i'm gonna kill myself but you guys all
have to kill yourselves with me because
who could go on living
if i'm not here
um
you know it'll be wild to join one of
those groups and just start heckling the
leader
you know especially if they're saying
that they're christ
oh yeah dude why don't you go walk on
some water i like when you you like
going going to join
did i ever tell you that time when i was
out here and somebody told me um
somebody you know i was looking for an
acting class
and this actor goes oh you should go to
this acting class right and i go over
there
and uh
you know i audit the class
and i'll tell you it was weird
like it was definitely a weird vibe
right
i'm sitting in the class and they would
say like
okay does anybody at the beginning of
class does anybody have any news
and somebody raises their hand and i go
this is the 90s so these tv shows are
going to be old
and the person raises their hand and
what's your news
i just booked an episode of jag
and then
the whole class like ridiculously loudly
starts cheering like whoa
like [ __ ] clap on their hands like
ridiculously
[ __ ] loud and i was like
all right what was that all about right
and then somebody else what do you say i
booked a two-episode arc
on uh on friends and then
everybody [ __ ] going nuts
so i'm thinking in my head why are they
cheering so overly loud and i was like
oh i get it i get it most acting classes
people get competitive and they get up
you know
your victory is my loss type of [ __ ] so
they're just like we're gonna be overly
positive this feels weird but whatever
it's an artsy thing and it's always
gonna be a little weird
so then the person goes um we have a
couple of new people here
auditing the class
and they go i just moved here from
[ __ ] new york city
please welcome bill burr and they did
the same [ __ ] ridiculously loud clap
and i'm like my face literally turned
like i was embarrassed my face turned
red this is when i was old billy shy boy
um
and uh
so during the break
you know and then you know that people
did some scenes and the actors were good
and everything so i was like all right
make they're a little weird whatever but
the acting's good
and the guy teaching the class is
[ __ ] one of my favorite actors this
is this is sorry i can get past this
[ __ ] right so then i i um
you know there's the break in the middle
and i go to meet
you know the person to sign up for the
classes
and they just kept going like okay this
is a very special place okay you know we
have our own parking
um you're gonna be safe here we have our
own security and everything that
this guy was saying was always our own
like our own in-house
and there was just something weird about
his vibe and so i was trying to break
the tension and i jokingly said i go
jesus christ i feel like i'm joining a
cult
and he sort of looked at me
and he didn't laugh and i was like
all right sorry and then we just
continued and i watched
i remember too the uh the acting teacher
in the middle he goes what do you think
about the beginning the class the uh
cheering was that uh
was that too much
it was all [ __ ] weird
so
as luck would have it
i ended up going down to the laugh
factory that night i ran this another
comedian that was also trying to act
and i was telling the story and he goes
what's the name of this place and i told
it to him he goes jesus christ bill he
goes that's scientology
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i got all [ __ ] weirded out i was
like oh my god
oh my god thank god i didn't drink
anything then i got all [ __ ] scared
or whatever
and uh
they just kept calling me
hey you coming down this week you know
because i'm my dumb ass i gave my phone
and they just kept [ __ ] like
jehovah's witnesses they just kept
calling
and i finally was just like yeah listen
i'm
i'm not going down there anymore and the
guy remember i still remember he goes oh
we lost you
it's yeah yeah yeah yeah you lost me
like you [ __ ] never had me a bunch of
weirdos
um
you know why can't scientology be normal
like the catholic church where they're
[ __ ] raping children and then moving
rapists around for [ __ ] along it's
not the religion
it's the rapists
um
so that was my one experience where i
almost uh
not really joined a cult it's a religion
i know a lot of people don't want to
admit that scientology is a religion but
it is a religion
and they're like oh this guy he just
[ __ ] made it up it's just like yeah
what is that teacher
somebody just made up catholicism they
just all of them
they're made up
um that's just my opinion
it's my opinion i think they're all
[ __ ] man-made
uh
you know i think part of it was good
well they were just like all right we
got to come up with some sort of like
invisible guy
that you're gonna answer to because if
not what's gonna stop people from just
being complete animals down here
then they came up with laws
it's really amazing with this podcast
how how much [ __ ] i just start to talk
about as if i've read up on it now i'm
gonna pass the information onto you then
they came up with laws is that what they
did bill i don't know
i have no idea
um
i do know i am gonna watch the red sox
again tonight i just i don't know
i like going through the whole [ __ ]
season
people just showing up when they're
doing well and then leaving
oh dude i'll do it i can't i can't watch
him i can't watch him unless what i want
to have happen happens
um
all right i've been doing a bunch of
spots this week
another reason why
[ __ ]
froggy voiced here um
getting ready for montreal do another
two spots tonight
then i go into uh
montreal i land i literally drop my bags
montreal comedy festival very excited i
get to practice mo franch
uh
i just want somebody to ask hey do you
go there and i can just be like gb
um
i've been cruising along dude i'm tell
you something that pimsleur french is
[ __ ] all right that app
that pimsleur app i'm like now listening
to french radio and
i still don't know
90 of the [ __ ] that they're saying but
all these other words i can never pick
out i'm now hearing
and i'm hearing the words like broken up
and there's been a couple of times where
there'll be like these eight-second
things where i was like i know what
they're talking about it's very exciting
so uh anyway i was been doing spots
uh the last two nights
did three spots on tuesday
sorry two spots
last night and now i'm doing two more
and that's the kind of [ __ ] you need to
be doing to get better or at least to
have your [ __ ] act where it's
supposed to be but i didn't uh
i haven't played drums for the last
couple of days so i gotta make sh i
gotta make
sure i can still do that good times bad
times lick i'm so afraid i'm gonna lose
it that it's now part of my warm-up
you know i do this these warm-up
exercises and then i play traveling
riverside blues
which is at 90 bpms and then i play good
times bad times two times in a row i'm
telling you it's a little sloppy but
it's getting better each time
and um
[ __ ] sight finally got over that
over that hump all right here we go
people let's do a little reads here diet
smoke
you know let's take a break
to tell you guys about diet smoke diet
smoke is the solution to avoid those oh
[ __ ] i'm way too high moments
diet smoke makes delta hthc delta 9 thc
oh good i was wondering i was hoping
they wouldn't just have the delta a thc
i'm very happy they have the delta 9
also and cbd products that are perfectly
balanced their gummies drinks and vapes
are not only delicious they get they are
guaranteed to give you that beautiful
buzz that you've been looking for
without melting you into the couch
they extract their thc and cbd from
american grown hemp meaning they can
ship directly to your door no
prescription no sketchy weed dealer no
need to even leave the house is there
somebody out there still dealing weed
illegally diet smoke just released and
is that illegal
dyed smoke just released a bunch of new
products and flavors so no matter what
type of mood you're in they got you
covered so if you're ready for that
perfect hi man head over to
dietsmoke.com and use the code bur
b-u-r-r for 15 off your your
entire first order that's promo code
burr for 15 off your first order must be
21 or older to order
all right back to the show they write
um not back to the show we have one more
read here
oh it's movement everybody mvmt
mike victor mike tango uh in a tiny
apartment in southern california two
college dropouts teamed up to create a
watch company that broke all the rules
then they both got bitten by a nuclear
reactive spider
they became a gay couple no with fair
prices unexpected colors and clean that
was gay spider-man which i just pitched
uh with fair prices unexpected colors
and clean original designs
uh
mvmt pronounced movement grew into one
of the fastest growing watch brands
shipping to over 160 countries across
the globe
now mvmt has expanded into blue light
glasses that protect your eyes from your
screens minimalist jewelry and more
style essentials that don't break the
bank all designed out of their
california headquarters
number one
first selling point
unbeatable price point movement watchers
have a look and quality of a four to
five hundred dollar watch uh you're
paying for a department store but cost a
fraction of the price because they were
built online and they own their process
from start to finish you get a beautiful
watch shipped right to your door for
free and if you don't love it you can
ship it right back for free
blue light glasses my favorite
uh i've got i got to spend all day in
front of my computer and my ever scroll
blue light glasses fill filtering
glasses are a game changer those are
great at night
at night when you're sitting there with
the laptop cooking your balls you know
you might be frying your balls but your
eyes feel great
um it really helps with ice you can see
the ball cancer coming through these
glasses if it really helps with the eye
strain and poor sleeping patterns i love
the modern style of the frames i love
looking stylish
i wear pajamas to bed like a 1950s
like husband on a tv show if you don't
want if you want to elevate your look
with style that doesn't break the bank
then join the
movement and get 15 percent off today
with free shipping and free returns
by going to
mvmt.com again that's mvmt.com
um anyway
sad [ __ ] news
speaking of uh
tv shows from the 1950s unfortunately
the legendary the great tony dow
passed away
um
he played uh obviously wally cleaver on
leave it to beaver
and um
i don't know man that [ __ ] blows
now jerry mathers is the only one left i
used to [ __ ] watch that show all the
time i always thought tony dow was cool
you know i always thought wally was cool
you know
he was jacked a little bit
his voice changed
you know everything that that that as a
little boy you wanted to be able oh [ __ ]
you know
don't be that athletic looking kid right
and i also liked him because i thought
he you know he never beat the [ __ ] out
of his little brother
[Laughter]
which surprised me
i was like that's his older brother how
come he's not [ __ ] throwing him down
the stairs for no reason
just because he can
oh the parents aren't home how come he's
not [ __ ] torturing him i mean that's
what brothers did back in the day
um
anyway yeah i remember you know speaking
of that watching uh
the uh
the brady bunch the last episode
when bobby washes greg's hair and it
turns orange
and robert reed thought it was such a
stupid episode he refused to be and none
of them knew that that was going to be
the last episode
um they thought they were coming back
and they just didn't get renewed so they
never had never got to do a finale so
that is the final episode and i remember
greg brady was like graduation's
tomorrow and i have orange hair and he
was [ __ ] pissed and he
really looked like he was gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of his little brother and i
wanted that to happen so bad
um
even though i didn't enjoy it when it
happened to me
anyway uh
rest in peace to a hollywood legend tony
dao
i'll leave it to beaver fame man
gone too soon
i think i know he was 77 but when you're
54 years old i'm like that's 23 years
away man
that's too [ __ ] soon uh and rest in
peace paul sorvino i kind of had this
feeling when ray liotta went i'm like
god no
now all the good fellow guys are gonna
go
uh
the great paul f sorvino now i gotta
turn my back on you what do i know about
running a restaurant
don't put too many onions in that sauce
paulie didn't like phones
um
how many [ __ ] legendary lines did he
have now we can eat
i [ __ ] quote i've been quoting all of
those lines
like 30 years great singing voice and
all that and everybody i know that ever
met him said he was just the greatest
guy ever
uh won a run years active 1956
to
2022 the guy almost had a 70-year career
incredible um
rest in peace though
passed away in jacksonville florida
from new york new york so oh that's all
right so he's probably down in florida
he's like semi-retired he wasn't paying
[ __ ] state taxes
he went out all right okay that makes me
feel good
um what do you guys think about weed man
now that cool wait a minute what's going
on here
now that um
it's it's legal
i don't know there's just something
about it man i feel like they're gonna
do the same thing with like mushrooms
because like mushrooms are gonna kind of
become legal i guess i heard like in
west hollywood they're gonna be able to
sell those things because they're
finding all of these great
um
health benefits for ptsd and all of this
type of stuff
uh possibly alzheimer's and dementia
they're fine you know
this stuff is all great
i just feel like the big pharmaceuticals
are gonna grab hold of it and they're
gonna start making synthetic mushrooms
that cause a whole bunch of other side
effects that they can then treat it's
really [ __ ] evil
um
because i feel like we got now that it's
legal is way less healthy
it's just way too [ __ ] intense
there's no there's just no way
i mean i never smoked weed when i was
growing up but i remember my friends
they would get high and they would just
giggle and that was it they didn't just
get you know to that point
of like
[ __ ] man i can't get out of this goddamn
chair like you can get that way like i
don't know maybe because
everybody's doing edibles now i just
hope you know against hope again you
know i just hope what i know they're
gonna do they don't [ __ ] do wouldn't
it be great if they actually figured out
that these natural psychedelics really
helped all of these people
that were um in pain
experience trauma
or um
you know we're starting to get forgetful
or whatever just imagine if it actually
does work and all that just imagine if
we just
let people
use the natural
um version of it
and it improved their life as opposed to
these big [ __ ] corporate [ __ ] who
once again like what exactly can they do
you know and and [ __ ] fox and cnn
those two horrible [ __ ] channels will
actually call them out
i did enjoy people saying oh fox news
was giving you a shout out about that
abortion bit it's like oh you know
you mean when they cut out the part
where i said i was pro-choice
i swear i can't get mad at them because
even people on twitter were doing it
even just your average individual acts
like a 24-hour
uh propaganda i mean news network
um
anyway sorry i don't want to get on a
[ __ ] rant about that [ __ ]
people the people that watch those
goddamn channels
um like how weak in the mind you have to
be i i watch a channel that tells me the
news the way i want to hear it
it agrees with my ideologies
and fills in all the areas where i don't
know what to think
morons morons watch she and then and
morons watch fox news and uh i don't
know why
maybe because it's just easy
yeah i think i feel like it's
i feel like news junkies in a lot of
ways or even dumber than sports fans
because at least what i'm watching is
real
the red sox really did lose seven to six
last night they're not putting their
[ __ ] spin on
it you know
i don't know well i guess you know the
nba is pretty [ __ ] manipulated all
right i'm not going down this [ __ ]
thing all right that is the podcast
everybody i have uh
i have some breakfast i got to go make
one of my favorite things to do i got to
go make breakfast for the kids
um that is it
go [ __ ] yourselves
go red sox
i'm still hanging in there
um
and uh have a great weekend all right
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday july 28 2014.
what's going on
how's it going i just got back from
monreal
canada doing the wonderful uh montreal
comedy festival i had an awesome time up
there
i hosted one of their galas
you know which is a big deal
and uh
you know i'm not big on hosting
i'm not big on hosting because i have my
bits are long
and it's sort of like i don't really
know how to write a joke so there's a
lot of cursing and making faces and i
build momentum off of that so i just
keep [ __ ] rolling with that
and before people realize that they've
listened to an hour of my [ __ ] and i get
out of there
but if i host i gotta keep coming back
out and i gotta get that energy going
again and um
you know it's [ __ ] exhausting so uh
to be honest with you i didn't want to
do it
you know so you're probably like well
bill then why why the [ __ ] did you say
yeah i'll do it i'll tell you why
because i bought the money pit house
that's why
i am out there whoring myself i'm gonna
tell you right now cause i was gonna
take the whole [ __ ] summer off i was
gonna take the rest of july and august
off because i toured like [ __ ] 18
months straight
and uh all over this great global
[ __ ] marble
and i was just like look i'm taking two
months off
i was gonna have a great [ __ ] time
i'm bringing bailey back yeah
and i was just gonna [ __ ] chill out
and grill
i was gonna sit on my [ __ ] back porch
i was gonna stare off into the [ __ ]
half a yacht that i have out here in la
which is actually considered a decent
yard do you know you can't throw a
frisbee in my backyard without hitting
something
i mean it right as it leaves your hand
it probably
if i go the long ways i decide i could
maybe float for just under three seconds
it's not really a yard i have an area
all right whatever um i live in a
metropolis
so anyways um
yes i was gonna take the whole summer
off and you know as these guys finished
this one thing that they were gonna do
the area that got damaged by the [ __ ]
water and
this is what i learned when your house
is [ __ ] like a hundred years old 90
years old whatever this thing is
it's just you have
90 [ __ ] years well let's say the
first 10 years
everything's going pretty smoothly about
from about 80 years in
all the way back 80 all the way up to
right now you just have one
do-it-yourself
[ __ ] job hey i got a guy i got a guy
see i'll do it for nothing yeah
it's the 1930s see there's a there's no
code
nothing
and when i tell you nothing i mean
nothing
nothing downstairs in my house
was up to code
nothing
i know what you guys are thinking like
well hey didn't you get somebody to
inspect the house when you bought it
yeah but they can't see into the [ __ ]
walls
you have no idea what's in you all they
can just look at it
you know they're looking for [ __ ]
sweat marks on the walls
smelling for water damage checking the
gas lines they can do that
right
but other than that you're pretty much
on your own and i'll tell you are you
guys [ __ ] listening right now if
you're laughing you have no idea what
the [ __ ] in your walls
you have no idea what some douchebag did
20 years ago because he bought the time
life
books those do-it-yourself [ __ ]
things and you have no idea what that
[ __ ] rewired
in your wall
under your floorboards i mean
so basically
downstairs is laid open at this point
like it's having open heart surgery okay
and every time
they think they got to the last thing
there's another thing i know what you're
thinking bill these guys downstairs
they're taking you for a ride oh yeah
i'm sure they are but what they're
finding is [ __ ] undeniable do you
know we
they got to this wall the other day
and of course you know it's got this
[ __ ] [ __ ] rotted out crap in front of
it they get rid of that we get
underneath that we get behind that and
at the baseboard it's just dry rot
the guy's barely touching it and it's
not like it's it's breaking off it's
turning into powder
like [ __ ] long chaney jr put this
board in when he was a struggling
[ __ ] actor that's how old this
goddamn house is
and
so they're like yeah we got to rebuild
this wall costs like four or 500 bucks
i'm like all right just [ __ ] do it
right
so they take down the
drywall plastic whatever the [ __ ] it is
and
you know
later on that day like i'm i'm running
around doing whatever i'm doing and the
contractor calls me up and he's actually
laughing
he's like bill you you you
you got to come over and
see this and i'm thinking in my [ __ ]
head like dude this isn't whatever
you're laughing about this isn't funny
and i got over there
and basically
behind the wall
is like this dirt right they have like a
you know this crawl space area and what
they had behind the wall is somebody had
taken like this see-through like plastic
tarp
and that was the that was the barrier
between the dirt and the wall
was this plastic [ __ ] thing and the
guy was laughing go hey
gotta tell you i've never seen anything
like this
which he probably has
but uh you know
i know i'm just a comedian but i know
that that's not the way you're supposed
to do something like that but the good
thing is
that is the final wall downstairs and of
course it couldn't have been it couldn't
be built right right
so um
in other words i'm going to be doing
some shows on the oddball tour this
later on this summer
ah [ __ ]
i swear to god and this is the thing too
i could have been a [ __ ] i could have
been like dude i don't give a [ __ ] just
put a [ __ ] wall in front of it and
[ __ ] the next guy but uh that's not the
way i'm wired oh what are you a hero now
bill no i was raised properly fix the
thing right just fix the [ __ ] thing
right because i'm not gonna have you put
a beautiful brand new wall in there with
that [ __ ] uh sandwich bag barrier
behind it and then what
i don't know what happens seem to be
working all right before they cut open
the wall
i don't know sorry i'm [ __ ] i i've
i've had it
i've had it with the goddamn downstairs
um
so that's what's going on so if you hear
drilling and if you hear all kinds of
[ __ ] going on that's the [ __ ] people
downstairs and uh we're hoping we're
hoping that they're going to be done you
know
initially was end of june beginning of
july now uh i don't even ask anymore
last i heard was end of august
early september and uh come on
i'm hoping by thanksgiving i can
actually walk down there my [ __ ]
slippers
you know we won't have any money for a
turkey
i'm gonna shoot a [ __ ] pigeon and i'm
gonna deep fry it and i'll do it the
wrong way i won't take into
consideration the space that the
pigeon's gonna take up and uh the grease
will go over and i'll light the whole
[ __ ] thing on fire we'll start over
again
oh god
oh jesus this is why i actually like
going on the road i like going on the
road because i don't have to listen to
the sounds
that's the sound of the money flying out
of your bank
account
um all right so i had i had an
unbelievable week uh aside
from um
going up to uh montreal montreal comedy
festival and seeing a bunch of great
comics um guys i started with people who
started uh before i did and then a bunch
of new faces that i went down and
checked out
um earlier this week i did a show out
here in la that i mentioned last week i
was talking to norton where i was gonna
uh
was gonna play drums with this band they
had this cool show like best god damn
comedy show or something
uh hosted by josh
adam myers
um
and uh
we basically uh
hang on a second what the [ __ ] is this
now
getting this [ __ ] text come on
this is you know what this is one of
these days like i should just i have to
get into the right
mindset because it's all gonna just
[ __ ] all right anyways plowing ahead so
uh joss adamers hosts this show he's got
a band
and basically knows a bunch of comics
that play guitar they sing or they play
drums or whatever and you basically you
go up you do stand up you do whatever
you want but you can kind of make it
music based and then in the end you uh
you interact with the band however you
wanted to do it so uh
you know i was like all right i'll play
drums we'll play a zeppelin song and i
was kind of thinking like all right
if i just go back there i can't remember
if i told this story last week i know i
told you guys that i was going to do it
but basically i'll fly through it here
i basically was thinking all right well
if i just go back and play drums and i
do a decent job that will be interesting
for like 30 seconds and then people will
have to sit through the rest of the song
so um
like a year ago i was gonna dress up
like john bonham for uh for halloween
and i they i ordered the t-shirt a
remake of the t-shirt that he wore uh
on that that concert film song remains
the same and i had the blue adidas
dragons turns out he's wearing a four
stripe adida when he was in seattle and
then i had the white pants i went out
and bought those
and my wife took me to a costume store
we got the [ __ ] wig
and the the led zeppelin one mustache
that he had you know
that was like a big thing with bonham
with like how long it took for his
mustache to connect into his beard
because his mustache wouldn't connect
into the beard and for the first like
three four albums he had that beard that
was that went like underneath his chin
like a [ __ ] chin strap like he had
nothing up there on his face and you
know what's sad is by the time his
mustache and beard connected
it's like he died
it was like his life's work was complete
um so anyways um
well i'll post some pictures if you
follow me on twitter i already posted a
few but i'll repost them for uh
for people who uh have lives and are not
on twitter
but anyway so i went back there i had a
great [ __ ] time we screwed it up
quite a bit we butchered it pretty good
but um
but it was still funny man it was a fun
time and uh
and for the longest time i was kind of
looking for a way that i could actually
play live drums and people would know
that i wasn't taking myself too
seriously
um and going up and dressing up and
looking like an idiot was kind of the
perfect way to do it and it also kind of
gave me license like i didn't have to
feel self-conscious that people were
looking at me because i had this whole
[ __ ] get up on with the sunglasses i
could kind of hide behind it it was
actually pretty uh
it was pretty cool so
i'm definitely gonna do another one
i'm trying to uh i think i already know
the song i'm gonna do in the drama that
i'm gonna dress up like and uh
i don't know it's gonna be a great time
it's gonna be a great time and the show
will get big and then somebody network
will come down they'll turn it into a tv
show and then they'll ruin it and
they'll take all the fun out of it so
i'll let you know when the next one is
uh so before people come in and try to
figure out how they're going to make
money off of it it's going to be a great
time so i'll let you know when the next
one is and you should definitely come
down now
uh as we're on the beginning of the
behind the music arc
on this idea uh but anyways but thanks
to everybody in the band and uh josh and
everybody for having me come down i had
a [ __ ] awesome time
so
and with that so that was my monday and
um
and then like i said uh i went up
what was it uh
thursday i flew up to montreal one of my
favorite cities
with uh
the team i don't like the most the
[ __ ] canadians i don't mind and
whatever
um oh you know what pk subon came down
to one of the gallons i thought he was
coming down to my gal i was really
excited to meet the guy because i wanted
to ask him about that whole uh
because it really seemed when
you know sean squirted the water in his
face
like we had him and then they did that
and then they just [ __ ] rallied and
they won game six and seven i just i was
dying to hear what the [ __ ] he had to
say on that
and uh of course he was at another gala
um oh well so anyway so i went up there
thursday and uh
landed
got over and did this show uh paul
provenza's uh green room and it was like
sort of this
remembering uh all the great comics
who've passed
that was uh
you know patrice schimel greg geraldo
uh
john panette
you know mitch hedberg and on and on and
on and on and on and we you know told a
bunch of funny stories and gave each
other [ __ ] i guess people enjoyed it
um robin schimmel i don't know if i said
him and uh
yeah if it was uh it was actually it was
a good time
um even though i was dreading it it
actually turned out to be a really good
time but then afterwards somebody
mentioned that we forgot to bring up
otto and jo um
otto and george and i was just like oh
man so i felt bad about that but
either way started off well
and um
and then just every night me versi
and uh tony v
the great tony v
ended up at a cigar bar every night at
the end smoking cuban cigars
and uh i gotta be honest with you i was
done after two nights i can't smoke a
cigar three nights in a [ __ ] row but
versey is a [ __ ] animal
and by the third night tony v had gone
back
so it was just me and verzing i actually
i got like a small one and even then i i
feel like i feel like i've stood i stood
behind a bus like usually i i buy a box
of cubans and i bring them back and at
this point i didn't even want them
it's like i need to i need to take time
off of this [ __ ]
this is too much
so um
i think i'm on the wagon again
you know i do it i either i i don't know
how to i either [ __ ] i'm gonna have
20 of them in [ __ ] cigars every night
or i just say [ __ ] it for like 60 70
days that's it works for me all right so
go [ __ ] yourself with your rolling of
your eyes
can't help it if i don't have any
willpower
actually i do have willpower
for 70 days and then i'm good
um but i want to thank tony v tony v um
i went up there and they were they had
this award show thing and they were
giving out these awards for comedy which
is you know
silly
but uh
you know
what are you gonna do
they've done a bunch of [ __ ] for me
it was anybody else i would have been
like no no i don't want to go you know
what i'm working
but it's the montreal comedy fest who
doesn't want to go to montreal so i went
up there and i had tony v
do the intro and he [ __ ] absolutely
crushed it
um
and uh i know that was that was that was
a great time and then the next night i
did the gala
and uh i got gotta give uh
i gotta give a shout out to the people
that were on the show man they were
great this dude mark forward
who i worked with in toronto
was hilarious and we had worked in
toronto like the end of last year and i
saw growth in him
like major growth since the last time i
was with him he was [ __ ] great
god damn i hope i don't forget anybody
michael che um
who i wasn't familiar with i made sure i
went on youtube and i watched everybody
before i went out there because i wasn't
allowed to say
he's been on this show or this show
because we were up in canada and i
watched his letter and she said the guy
was phenomenal and then his jokes at the
gala were even better
ah
[ __ ] i'm getting old oh verzi verzie was
on the show
um
nikki glazer she was on it
um
looks how old i am the show was
literally two days ago oh and then
crystalia
he comes out
absolutely [ __ ] murders it he's a
beast and then domino walked out closed
it out
oh wait
uh bert
um
kurt metzger i almost said bert
kreischer that's how [ __ ] old i am
kurt metzger came out he did this
[ __ ] bit
and what killed me was the the
i don't want to ruin the joke
because i don't want to do his bits but
he did this bit and he was so clearly
being absurd
and it was [ __ ] hilarious it was a
bit about
you know girls in their teens committing
suicide and he had a solution as to what
to do to prevent them from not killing
themselves
and it was [ __ ] hilarious it was
absurd but the the reviewer was just
like it didn't go over well at the the
gala it did go well on the nasty show
it's like yeah
that's not his fault
you [ __ ] idiots do you think he's
being serious that there's nothing that
gets oh a lot of [ __ ] gets me going but
that really [ __ ] annoys me when the
critic doesn't even get the joke and
then blaming the comedian
whatever all right
so he [ __ ] killed
and though every the whole [ __ ] show
was great the show was great and i was
actually uh i was dreading doing it
because like i said i was hosting and
that was outside of my comfort zone
um
you know what i you know what it is it
goes back to early in my career
where i hosted a show at the comedy
connection in providence rhode island
and i ate my balls so [ __ ] bad
and the thing about it is
is if you're just doing a set if you go
up and bomb
as bad as it is you're tearing that
you're tearing the band-aid off whatever
you're doing you're doing 10 minutes
you're getting it over with you're doing
it it's getting it's going by in real
time if you're hosting
you go up and eat your balls you get off
you got to go back up
again bring up the next eat your balls
bring up the next guy go back up again
you just have to keep going back up
and
and it's not like you get to start over
again they're like oh yeah that guy that
guy that we don't like and it just keeps
going on and off for the the duration of
the show which is going to be at least
90 minutes so for 90 minutes you're
eating your balls
even when you're not up there eating it
you're in the green room dreading and
you're making a setlist what if i did
this joker freaking the [ __ ] out
uh so i think that i i actually have a
uh i have a phobia
or i did anyways had a phobia of [ __ ]
hosting and that uh that got rid of it
you see that when you got dry rot on the
bottom of your [ __ ] house you can get
over a lot of fears
all right
let's get into the uh the advertising
for this week everybody um stance.com
quick convenient and most importantly
easy to use that's how i would describe
stamps.com it will make your mailing and
shipping a breeze
oh for [ __ ] sakes hold on a second
this
construction people hold on hold on god
damn it
all right i'm back jesus [ __ ] christ
can we shut off the water for just an
hour
hang on let me ask my wife
oh jesus all right where was i
all right with stamps.com buy and print
official us postage using your computer
and printer there's nothing to learn
stamps.com will give you a digital scale
it automatically
calculates exact the exact postage for
any letter any package they'll even help
you choose the best class of mail to get
your mail on time for the least amount
of money then drop your mail into any
mailbox or hand it to your mailman or
male lady
and you're done you'll never have to go
to the post office again everybody trust
me mailing and shipping has never been
easier right now use my last name bur
b-u-r-r for this special offer no risk
trial plus 110 bonus offer offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur bur that
stamps dot com enter bur
all right
dollar shave club everybody the big
razer companies think we're stupid every
year they roll out some ridiculous
shaving technology gimmick right and x
and expect us to shell out our big bucks
for it do you really need a razor with a
vibrating handle
how about a roller pivot ball back
scratcher egg timer laser pointer
corkscrew you get the point you don't
need it i know i don't we were shaving
just fine before any of that junk and i
definitely don't need to spend my hard
earned cash on it
if you're sick of being treated like an
idiot join the hundreds of thousands of
smarter people who joined the
dollarshaveclub.com revolution dollar
shave club delivers the best blades and
grooming supplies for just a few bucks a
month their blades are better than the
big shaving companies for a fraction of
the price it's perfect they deliver them
right to your door you always have a
nice shop blade i wish they had this
when i was a kid my listeners can get
started now at dollarshaveclub.com
and hey if you already if you're already
a member you gotta check out their new
doctor cabbies
post shave lotion it's the perfect way
to make peace with your face after the
disruptive act of shaving by the way
after shaving lotion lotion underrated
underrated you got to use this stuff
stop getting ripped off by the big shave
companies join dollarshaveclub.com
burr that's dollarshaveclub.com
and uh lastly but not leastly on this
little
ad chunk prosper lending
in 72 hours you could have 35 000 to
cover your needs what will you do pay
off high rate credit cards start a
business do that home improvement
project oh jesus host
um ad i'm the worst that was me add
something you'd like to do with that
money i know what i'd like to do i'd
like to pay an uh extra crew to finish
off downstairs
um with our sponsor prosper it's never
been easier go online answer a few
questions and see how your low fixed
rate
wait a minute slow down bill go online
answer a few questions and see your low
fixed rate in seconds your money hits
your account in as few as three days
and as few as three days uh prosperous
prospers the fastest growing
peer-to-peer lender and they facilitated
over one billion dollars in loans to
people like you their revolutionary
platform connects people looking to
borrow money
with those who
have money to invest there's no
outrageous fees no raising interest
rates and you'll never set foot in a
bank just go to prosper.com slash bur
b-u-r-r to check your rate instantly
without affecting your credit score
that's nice for a limited time prosper
is offering my listeners a 50 visa
prepaid gift card when you get the loan
go to prosper.com burr thirty five
thousand dollars in just three days and
a fifty dollar gift card go to
prosper.com
all right
here we go back to the thing there
you know one of these weeks i'm actually
gonna look at the copy before i go to
read it
i always do that personal experience or
i go host
what a maroon um
all right so anyway so now that i'm i'm
i'm trying to convince myself that i'm
going to knock off the drinking whenever
i quit booze i have to go like six days
i can go like three four days and i
don't give a [ __ ] if i have a beer but
once i get to six days i feel like i got
a little hitting streak going you know
and i don't want to start back over at
zero
so uh we'll see how i am this time next
week but i'm gonna lay off the stoves
gonna lay off the booze there
and um
like i said we'll we'll see how it goes
and i'm trying to do my final push
to tip the scales at a buck 62. the last
time i had a flat stomach and a little
bit of abs over there
and i got to be honest a lot of people
are giving me [ __ ]
for my diet advice despite the fact that
i know some people that have been you
know some of the suggestions that i'm
making
you know quinoa salads and all that type
of stuff somebody actually texted me
saying your diet advice is making me
angry
and it's just like dude i think that has
less to do with what i'm saying i'm
suggesting vegetables vegetables are
making you angry
i think that has to do with you probably
had you know an overbearing father like
myself
you know we didn't let you speak up and
express your opinions you could just
write me and just say hey you know uh
why don't you try this
instead of sitting there stewing
um no pun intended
and then there's other people that you
know they're giving me [ __ ] just saying
that veggies are for rabbits and all of
that that all of that usual [ __ ] i never
said don't eat meat
i'm just saying i just what's been
working for me i'm in the best shape
i've been in like three years and
everybody's saying my dietary advice is
[ __ ] it's completely working for me
they're still holding on to that whole
you know eat like a man
you know [ __ ] go
kill an animal and go eat it i'm not
saying don't do that [ __ ] but uh
here's something
here's something uh
i would like you to try for all the meat
eaters out there that are giving me [ __ ]
and i'm not even saying they're so
[ __ ] paranoid
carnivores
i'm not even saying don't eat meat i'm
just saying you know twice a [ __ ]
week this is what i do with the veggies
over there and they're getting their
backs up they're getting all freaked out
let me ask you this there steak dinner
i want you to do a little experiment all
right one night go out and get yourself
a lovely amazing steak dinner with the
baked potatoes and the cream of spinach
and your glass of wine and all of that
and i want you to honestly tell me how
you feel afterwards i know you feel full
i know you feel great but i want to know
how long after that meal before you just
have to lay down and go to sleep
which is basically your body going wow
look at this [ __ ] mountain of work we
got to deal with
let me just go [ __ ] lie down
let's shut the body down so we can get
this through our [ __ ] system
if you go out and you have a [ __ ]
veggie dinner right
that's of the same quality of as a good
steakhouse i mean i'm not talking about
going to one of those things where they
deep fry
[ __ ] zucchini
at that point you might as well go to
mcdonald's i'm saying actually a really
you know
like comparable to whatever steakhouse
you're going to go to a comparable
vegetarian place and uh tell me how you
feel after that
okay and i will always eat steak
i love a [ __ ] steak dinner i love
chicken i love all of that [ __ ] i'm
always gonna eat that stuff but um it's
undeniable
as far as i'm concerned
how much better i feel
when i do the veggie thing
so i know i'm never going to stop eating
cattle
so i just look at it kind of like with
the stogies hey i just take a break for
a couple of days that's all i'm
suggesting
all right so all you guys who are
sending me homophobic [ __ ]
suggesting that i now want to lay down
with another man just because i want to
have a [ __ ] cucumber
[Laughter]
well dude look at the shape of it
cucumbers like a [ __ ] porn star's
dick you know it's like you're blowing
the hulk
[Laughter]
um anyways hey this is a great time of
the year it's actually getting a little
late you know i hope you guys i forgot
to bring up again once again to to have
yourself a little veggie garden
you know our tomatoes are just starting
to become ripe and the other night uh
one of them fell off the the branch
there
and uh we cut it up
put a little salt and pepper drizzle
olive oil made it a little i guess less
healthy
[ __ ] ate the thing i was unbelievable
unbelievable what a tomato is actually
supposed to taste like versus what the
[ __ ] you usually get
um
so anyway so all you guys out there who
think i'm like you know slowly going to
start
you know walking on stage wearing yoga
stretchy pants
um
i mean i might have to do that one night
if uh
if
you know that uh josh's show there the
best goddamn comedy show whatever the
[ __ ] he calls it
you know
depending on what drummer i'm dressing
up like i mean if you look at a lot of
the hair metal and that type of stuff
some of that spandex i mean they were
basically wearing yoga pants that were
shorts right
is that what it was
i want to do a striper song
joking i would never do that to people
um anyway so that's all i'm suggesting
so everybody can uh you know [ __ ]
relax
can relax
um
what else did i do up in montreal
besides booze my face off
oh i did radio it did some radio i did
uh rich and bonnie's podcast
going in there knowing full well that it
was going to be some of the most awkward
moments in the history of of radio which
is basically what a podcast is i don't
know why they call it a podcast it's a
[ __ ] radio show um what is this
podcasting how would you describe it
well have you listened to the radio it's
that except it's on the internet
um interesting
um
so if you've never listened to the
rich and bonnie podcast my wife hates me
uh
uh i would i would highly recommend it
and i went on this thing knowing that it
was gonna be brutal
and uh
and then me and bonnie we got this
[ __ ] thing where we like each other
but our conversations do not link up
you ever have something like that some
of you just you just cannot
like you just
it's just been a 20-year
misunderstanding between the two of us i
never know what she's saying she never
knows what i'm saying
and it just leads us
to these [ __ ]
dead ends
where we just both look at each other
shake our heads and walk away and then
start over again at the top of the
street
so that's essentially if you'd like to
listen to like an hour of that
with rich foss telling stories that
really have nothing to do with what me
and bonnie are attempting to say to one
another i highly recommend it i'm
[ __ ] around it was a great time
uh people really seemed to enjoy it and
then also there was some really funny
comics in the crowd
um judy gold
uh you know people like that chiming in
and that type of stuff adding to it so
and this one old guy who fell asleep two
minutes into it we actually sent him
sorry she said the hiccups
i wasn't getting emotional we actually
sent him
off into the corner so he could sleep
and his friends could watch
and uh he nodded off for the whole show
i think we got a picture of him um
all right and then that was it i did the
opium jimmy show
and uh
i think that that was it that's what
that's what i did that was my festival
and another one another montreal comedy
festival down the [ __ ] tubes um
all right
hey you know don't look now but the new
york yankees are making a push for the
playoffs
those sons of [ __ ] are actually in
the wild card
and um
as a fan of derek jeter i'd like to see
him make it just to cg to do one more
postseason of course i want to see the
yankees lose which is always bigger
is bigger than uh my respect for derek
jeter but uh
i don't know be kind of sad if that was
like you know
[ __ ] end of the season
and then that was just it
i do have tickets to the uh
to that that last game he's playing at
fenway park did i tell you guys i bought
in half on red sox season tickets this
year
buddy of mine was on a waiting list for
10 years and he got these great seats
he's like i can't i can't swing these
man i need some more people to buy in so
i bought in for my little block of
tickets
me and a couple other guys or whatever
and um because they're expensive as [ __ ]
and i'm thinking like all right well you
know i got enough family and friends
back there that i can sell them to them
and then i can you know
the socks don't care if you put them up
on stubhub so i'm like i'll i'll be fine
right
and uh you know
the red sox [ __ ] the bed from day one
and i can't give these things away i've
lost my shirt on these tickets
once again bill burr on the comedy
oddball tour later on this summer
um
jesus [ __ ] christ so but i do have
that you know what's funny is i could
actually sell the now i could sell that
pair of tickets on stubhub and i could
make a ton of [ __ ] money
a ton of my money back i would still
lose
but especially if the yankees don't make
the playoffs and that could actually be
like his last [ __ ] game i think
it's a possibility
um
uh
this is a sports fan there's no [ __ ]
way
i'd rather be there
i've never been like you know i remember
a long time ago two two of my buddies
they got
season tickets to the patriots in 1985
and the patriots ended up going to the
super bowl and they had
tickets to go to super bowl 20 and they
both scalped them and i just i thought
it was the dumbest thing
ever and even though we lost 46 to 10
even though we got [ __ ] destroyed
it's just like i would i would still
rather go to super bowl 20
and actually see
the 46 defense live you could have saw
walter payton
all of those uh
you know richard dent wilbur marshall
all of those [ __ ] hall of famers all
of those people you could have seen you
know jim mcmahon
versus [ __ ] tony eason and then old
steve grogan coming in that whole fight
but it would have been great and you get
to party down in new orleans i i
definitely i always think the experience
even if your team loses is way better
than selling i mean maybe uh
maybe i'm a [ __ ]
jackass but i always look at it that way
so i'm definitely going back
for that game
you know maybe i'll pick up like a
one-nighter along the way
um
but uh i'm really looking forward to
going to that wow so maybe i should be
rooting for the yankees not to make the
playoffs so that'll be his last game so
actually they'll be like
in like the [ __ ]
bottom of the eighth of the top of the
ninth
derrick jeter coming up for his final
[ __ ] at bat
what if he hits a home run to right
field like [ __ ] ted williams you know
he's gonna do something um so anyways uh
and
football is right around the corner
this is such an exciting time is
anything more exciting than when you see
when they start going to like [ __ ]
training camp the greatest month of the
year for me is september
it's just like
i always get depressed at how like fast
the summer goes by and then when all of
a sudden it's september
and it's football and the games count
and there's college football and all of
that type of [ __ ]
it's just it's the greatest
it's the [ __ ] greatest i can't wait i
can't wait so i mean what else am i
gonna do for the rest of the summer huh
go out and sunbathe over there
all right
let's get into some of your questions
here for the week uh the flute
says bill you took a hammering from a
lot of people on all fronts twitter
facebook and emails
um
9
10. mentioned oh ninety percent i guess
mentioned anchorman others suggest you
youtube jazz flute players listen go
[ __ ] yourselves
all right first of all all you guys who
said when i said there's no cool way to
play the flute and then you bring up
anchorman
he was mocking playing jazz flute he was
making fun of it
it's a [ __ ] movie do you think those
flames were actually real
coming out of the end of it do you think
he really drank a [ __ ] drink out of
the thing it was using it as a straw it
was a joke
all right
uh and as far as jazz flute let me tell
you something right now i don't i'm not
saying that there's not virtuoso play i
don't want to hear it
there's certain instruments
that
listen if you want to accompany like
some [ __ ]
with the flute
absolutely all right but there's a
reason why there's no [ __ ] flute
players in the rock and roll hall of
fame and don't even bring up
that [ __ ] banner
whatever that [ __ ] guy is
that jethro told guy i don't even want
to [ __ ] hear it he did not get into
the rock and roll hall of fame because
of his flute playing it was the [ __ ]
rock music underneath it
okay so you can take your flute
turn it up sideways and shove it
straight up your candy ass no
um
yeah no i stand by that
i stand by that i put the flute right up
with the yobo now if i go watch a
classic i guess i was talking to like
rock music
all right
even jazz you can go [ __ ] yourself i'd
much rather a trumpet has so much more
power saxophone trombone all of that
[ __ ] i would rather listen to that than
the goddamn fluke now you take a flute
and a piccolo and you stick that [ __ ] in
a a sympathy sympathy a symphony
i can listen to it then
then i find it an amazing accompaniment
if you had i can't say any of the words
i'm trying to use right now if you
[ __ ] have
40 other [ __ ] musicians
okay helping to flesh out all around a
[ __ ] flute i can listen to it or a
piccolo
i can listen to that if you want to have
one little movement
where you know you got some dreadful
[ __ ] music and all is lost and all of
a sudden there's a ray of light
at the top of the [ __ ] tunnel and you
wanna you wanna emphasize that with a
little oh
what is that up there kind of [ __ ]
notes with a flute or a piccolo have at
it
have at it but i don't wanna listen to a
[ __ ] hour of that [ __ ]
i stand by it [ __ ] all you flew playing
[ __ ] [ __ ] out there who would
have thought
who would have thought that that would
have become a controversy
all right um hey bill when's your next
special
going to be available on netflix um we
are shooting for december 5th
december 5th is going to be the release
date and i'm editing it right now and i
could not be happier with the way that
this thing looks
i can't wait for you guys to see it and
i'm in the process of writing my new
hour
and i coming right out of the gate with
a uh it's a rough one you know
um
it's really just coming off as sexist
and i have to be honest because i can't
stand outside of myself
i can't have like a jesus christ what
are they ripping up downstairs now
you know what i think they're doing i
think they're getting rid of this is
actually exciting i have all this
galvanized pipe in my house
um
and they [ __ ] yank because like i
said it's been filled downstairs and you
can see all of it
and they're like well we might as well
change it now before it bursts
they always put that fear in your head
hey we're building this beautiful
bathroom but
sure would be a shame if this [ __ ]
behind the wall bursts
i mean we can risk it and you're like
all right just [ __ ] do it
i'm not gonna make any money off this
house i'm gonna have to [ __ ] live to
be 150.
oh christ this is
the only good thing about buying a
[ __ ] house is that if you want to
change something you can you don't have
to clear with your landlord but as far
as making any money off your house it's
a [ __ ] pipe dream unless you [ __ ]
start [ __ ] over other people and when
the market's hot you go in and you buy
houses and you do a half-assed [ __ ]
job
you half-ass the whole [ __ ] thing
you don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
doing that's why i hate that show where
they flip this house i can't stand
watching those people who aren't caught
like they sit there and they'll show the
guy who bought the house he's trying to
figure out how to use this the the uh
the sander or whatever to to redo
hardwood floors he doesn't even know
what he's doing they're playing this
silly music
and he does a [ __ ] half-assed job and
then you watch these suckers come in
because what he did is all brand new so
it's still holding together and it
hasn't fallen apart yet he just watching
these people getting let off to [ __ ]
financial slaughter
sorry
anyways um
so this opening bit that i'm doing i
can't tell if uh
if it's coming off sexist or i just am
sexist
um the point of it is is not the is
isn't sexism but it's really coming off
like that it's really been a especially
up there in montreal oh jesus
i opened with that at the gala i'm sure
they'll edit that one out
um
so anyways yeah the next one it's gonna
be uh december 5th
and also my comedy album
um is finally done finally went through
all the red tape with carnegie hall
finally got them pressed all the the
records pressed um i'm gonna find out
today i actually have them in my house i
have to find out when
i can sell these things to you because
they're also going to be
available in stores
but the [ __ ] is done
and i think i'm going to be doing a
co-release
with uh aziz ansari on uh third man
third man records which is jack white's
label
out of uh nashville tennessee so uh
that's a little teaser
that should be coming up in the next um
[Music]
i don't know when in the next month or
so i hope i'm really hoping
uh i think they're finishing up aziz's
album so uh it's gonna be pretty cool
and once again i really want to make
this stress this okay
the material that's on my carnegie album
is
um that was november of 2011 and when i
taped you people are all the same that
was march of 2012 so that's december
uh
january february march four months later
so this was where my act was at four
months earlier so there's a ton of
overlap which is why i wanted to put it
out
on vinyl only because
i wanted to document that i actually got
to perform at carnegie hall but i don't
want to [ __ ] any you guys over where
you're thinking this is going to oh my
god this is this is going to be
an hour of completely different [ __ ]
that i never heard of
it that's not what it is what you're
going to hear is where my act was four
months before i recorded it so there is
some different [ __ ] but i'd have to say
at least 80 percent of it is the same um
jokes ideas or whatever and granted i
tell them differently
i'm sure someone will listen to him be
like i actually like the way you did the
[ __ ] jerk off joke at carnegie better
than you did it in dc so there will be
that but i'm letting you guys know that
[ __ ] so i don't want to hear any [ __ ]
crap from any of you like i screwed you
over i'm going out of my way
to let you know that this is what it is
but um
it's really uh
you know to have
a comedy album you know is pretty
[ __ ] awesome and it's something that
i don't think this will be
the last time i do this i would like to
try and uh
you know i have a couple of ideas where
i could put out just an hour of original
[ __ ] maybe just out on vinyl
that could be a cool thing we'll see we
shall see so i'm just letting you know
that that is uh i actually have them i
just have to wait to figure out when i'm
going to sell them but every day that i
don't is closer to the holidays and
it'll make a wonderful gift
there you go oh jesus what is that guy
drilling down there
um
if any of the construction people are
working on my house are listening to my
podcast i know you guys are doing a
phenomenal job all right i'm just being
a crabby [ __ ] okay so don't [ __ ] not
tighten down the screws down there okay
you hear that
yeah
i don't even know i didn't want to know
what the [ __ ] that was
um
all right
let's plow ahead here uh
dude he didn't call [ __ ]
versi
um dear bill
uder is that like uber
uh i'd like to congratulate paul verzi
when no one else in the world was saying
lebron would go back to cleveland he was
the only one oh no wait he wasn't in
fact he didn't call it until one week
before the decision was made and plenty
all in caps of other people had been
making that exact same prediction you
can look at his twitter feed or listen
to his podcast for proof basically
everyone was saying it
it was either miami cleveland or a few
other teams that had made phone call
does paul know that guessing correctly
by picking one of four choices isn't
calling it jesus paul you're taking a
pounding
he acts like he's sam [ __ ] rothstein
and he may and he
he made some
some out of left field prediction that
lebron was going to the raptors or
something here's the thing i like paul i
think he's funny but holy [ __ ] cool it
on the calling it thing i can't even
imagine having an argument with him in
person uh this is [ __ ] hilarious paul
look at this guy this guy's sharing my
view of you
um he seems you know what's funny he's
paul is listening to this right now and
i know he's got his head down
with his looking through his eyebrows
going it's [ __ ] [ __ ] i said it to
j lawhead jayla can say it i said it two
[ __ ] years ago to j lawhead in a bar
in cleveland um he goes he seems like
the type of guy who does that thing
where he puts the tip of his fingers
together when he's making a point no he
definitely doesn't do that then shakes
his hands back and forth
uh from his chest to the floor like an
italian an italian and do that annoying
thing where you look at someone else in
the group besides the guy you're making
a point to as if to say hey we're all
together on this point i'm making
against this guy in front of me am i
right fellas that's [ __ ] that's
hilarious that's why i love italians
i love that they do that uh he goes all
due respect to paul though great guy now
that you took the piss out of him he
goes he literally has to be the worst
poker player on the planet too i can't
imagine him playing it cool with
anything but pocket aces watching paul's
face and paul's face alone during the
whole process of him chasing a straight
would be priceless
um i played poker with paul no he has
he has a great uh he has a great poker
face and then he has a way of looking at
you
he's got this face when he's looking at
you to try to figure out if you're
bluffing that actually makes you laugh
um
all right paul
shot has been fired your way for those
of you not listening to the versi
podcast this is like uh like the old rap
battles where paul's gonna have an
answer song
um
to this guy he's gonna defend himself so
everybody listen to the uh the versi
effect i will email this
i will copy and paste this and i will
email it to him and maybe uh
maybe he can write back
and uh the worst part of all of this is
i'm gonna have to listen to him
defending himself
first to me on the phone before i listen
to him do it on his podcast so i have to
listen to him do it twice
all right
okay quit drinking would rather be alone
this next person says uh
mr
embarrassant
embarrassment sorry
um i thought since you've taken time off
from drinking that you'd be a good
person to talk uh to talk to and ask
about this i'm 22 years old and after
hitting the bottle hard since early high
school i decided to take some time off
after it seemed to get out of control
yeah i've been there
i said i've been sober for nearly five
months at this point the thing is that
since putting up the bottle i've noticed
i enjoy spending time alone rather than
with other people
i still go out to bars and hang with my
buddies who drink and usually just end
up being the designated driver
he says i have no problem with people
who can control their alcohol just
thought it'd be a good personal choice
to take some time away but being
sober slash the sober guy at 22 is
pretty damn rough when everyone else is
getting shitty just wondering if you had
any insight on the matter
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself um
well i can actually relate even at 46 of
being the sober guy because of uh all
the free time that comedians have
um
we can kind of drink like we're still
22. so
i know how uh
um i guess you know but i'm not 22. so i
guess there is an extra amount of stress
with that but uh i think what you're
doing is a great thing
and uh hello nia hi
um
i think it's a great thing
and uh
how do i put this
when you when you go on a run of not
drinking it's all about you
okay and what you want to do and how
long you want to do it and
um i wouldn't give in to any like
external pressures as to when and
where you start drinking again
i always find it funny when i'm not
drinking to go to a bar and watch
basically everybody's slowly roofing
themselves
and then just watch the behavior and
like i said i don't do it in a
judgmental way because it's more
kind of observing like oh this is how i
was acting
um it can definitely suck at night but
there's nothing better in the morning
when you wake up without a hangover
ready to take on the world and uh i
would think at 22 to do that's pretty
mature and you got a chance
of meeting uh your judgment on who you
start dating would probably be a lot
better rather than you're hammered and
she's hammered and you start the
relationship off in this cloudy area
um you might meet another
you know smart person your age
uh who's taking some time off herself
who knows who knows but as far as like
um
if you're feeling pressure to start
drinking again that's the wrong reason
to start drinking because everybody else
is drinking is not the reason to come
back it but you know if you feel like
you have it under control
and you know you you know or
if there's an event coming up being like
okay i'm gonna drink it that and then
i'm gonna immediately shut it off but i
gotta be honest with you that's a tough
thing to do because i i was like i'm
gonna drink when i went to vegas and
then i was immediately and go back on
the wagon and i was able to do it for
four days and then it was like july 4th
weekend then i have had a beer and then
i've just been kind of drinking ever
since but uh
fortunately i drank so much in montreal
that yeah that now i don't wanna drink i
think that i almost need to do that i
gotta hit like a wall
where i either make such an ass of
myself and make such a bad decision or
just do something that uh it's it's
easy for me to kind of like want to walk
away from it but uh
like i said it's all up to you you don't
sound like you're an alcoholic i mean
from your [ __ ] email i can't really
judge it but like i said whatever do
whatever you want to do but don't don't
go don't start drinking again because
everybody else is i guess that that
would be my advice
um
all right let me let me read the last of
the advertising here then i'll wrap it
up
some other questions here uh all right
legal zoom everyone uh most americans
don't have a will but why you don't want
the court dictating what you just
pointed at me i know i got to do this
i'm doing this during this break uh you
don't want the court dictating what
happens to your property in minor
children
so why procrastinate most people say too
expensive or too time consuming my
answer legalzoom.com too expensive
legalzoom makes
makes prices
what legalzoom
legalzoom's prices just make sense i
swear to god i'm dyslexic too
time-consuming it just takes 20 minutes
and legalzoom guides you through from
start to finish the service was
developed by some of the best legal
minds in the country and they made it
painless for you to get the legal help
you need in fact helping people get
legally protected has been their missing
mission and passion for over 13 years
during national make a will month get
special pricing on wills and living
trusts by entering bur b-u-r-r in the
referral box at checkout again that
discount code is burr it's national make
a will month so don't wait protect your
family protect your future at legalzoom
today legalzoom was developed by top
attorneys to provide self-help services
at your specific direction however they
are not a law firm legal zoom um illegal
help is furnished through vetted
independent attorneys legalzoom.com
discount code burr burr and lastly but
not leastly hulu plus everyone you've
probably tried hulu on your computer
hulu plus is so much more
with hulu plus you can watch your shows
uh watch shows on your schedule i love
this by the way hulu plus has all of
your favorite shows like cosmos a space
odyssey bob's burgers or un undateable
starring crystalia and watch every
episode of shows like south park the
cosby show doctor who a bunch more hulu
plus works on your computer smart tv
roku apple tv xbox pretty much any
streaming device you already own
you should be blocking off a day just to
binge with hula plus you're in total
control to stream these and thousands
more as much as you want where whenever
you want also get exclusive access to
stream this
criterion collected collection movies
and hulu plus has all of them all movies
and kids shows are ad-free too for only
7.99 a month get your shows anytime
anywhere but right now i'm offering my
listeners a two-week free trial when you
go to hulupus.com
bill that's a whole extra week for
absolutely free please make sure you use
huluplus.com bill so you get that
extended free trial
and so that they know that we sent you
it helps us to keep the lights on and
gives you a better deal one more time
for the extended free trial that's
huluplus.com
bill
um oh hey for that kid also who's
talking about not drinking
um here's another thing too you know
at my age
i i see
i see the results
of uh abusing your body with booze drugs
food
people say food is a drug which i would
actually 100 agree with
um
you see the results of it and um
unfortunately when i was up in montreal
i saw
a couple of people that are my age and
10 years older
and they either look
the ones that took care of themselves
and kind of quit drinking and and tried
to eat right and that type of thing they
look great they still got the light in
their eye and then people who've been uh
you know
hitting it hard man it really
catches up with you when you get to be
my age where it's like um
you know i've been of legal drinking age
longer than i've lived when i wasn't
you know what i mean that tipping point
of like 42 years of age when you've uh
you know and forget about underage
drinking that you've already been doing
it really really catches up with you so
what you're doing right now giving your
body a break when it's as young as it is
is a phenomenal thing to do
and um
you know you could actually experiment
steering even more into a healthier
lifestyle like learning how to eat a
little bit better because at 22 man i
mean you can [ __ ] drink a 12-pack and
eat mcdonald's
late at night and wake up the next day
with a flat stomach but like you're
setting yourself up
for uh
you know
just basically being a human being is no
different than being an athlete it's
just the timeline timeline is stretched
out a lot longer like father time is
going to get all of us but
um
you know
those athletes who throughout their
career early in their career took care
of themselves have longer careers
and if you'd like to have a longer
career in other words a longer life like
doing what you're doing is a great thing
so uh
i don't know when you look at it that
way there's really no peer pressure is
there really peer pressure to die sooner
um all right nia do you want to chime in
on one of these
sure
um you want to do dead nancy uh did
nancy dead nazi grandpa
did i say nancy
do you know how hard they're laughing in
england right now [ __ ] nancy boy uh
breaking up for college
which one do you want to do
you want to do that
you want to stay in your wheelhouse yes
all right
i'll come over here
who wears short shorts
all right
that's really good about
quitting drinking i'm not drinking this
week
i'm a little closer i'm not drinking
this week i said
okay
it's a good idea it is a good idea
all right here we go breaking up for
college
uh
oh yeah look at that what is this this
is this is she just picked up my hotel
key for this weekend that's the w hotels
that that's how they advertise their spa
and there's a girl on it wearing a
bikini
sitting on luggage
and holding like a hat box
so fit avec avec tara styles
is she like a trainer there there's
literally a picture of like a half naked
woman on your room key
yeah i mean i said that a long time ago
i did the w hotel everything looks like
it's been [ __ ] on
i don't know no they have all they have
of that hungover lighting and all of
that type of you're making a mistake
lamps you know very sexy
now it's hacky sexy that aquarium
lighting that they have and all of it i
i've decided i'm i'm done with them i'm
done with them i like those older
stuffier places with the good breakfast
oh i want some holiday sauce
i say holidays holidays holidays
hollandaise
how many times i've read that and i
still can't retain it all right breaking
up for college dear bill my girlfriend
and i have been dating for a while
throughout high school it's pretty much
the relationship i've always dreamt of
never really getting tired of each other
no fighting similar views and tastes a
healthy amount of sex
sounds like a recipe
and a healthy scoop of sex very
supportive of each other however we both
graduated high school and are going off
to college she's going to a liberal arts
school in philly while i'm staying in
the state uh to go to northern arizona
university we both agreed that it would
be
it wouldn't be healthy to try and
maintain a long-distance relationship so
we're spending these last few weeks of
the summer together and we'll break it
off when she leaves for philly oh wow
man that sounds sad um
i couldn't for high school this is a
person who just graduated for from high
school yeah and they're talking about
it's pretty much the relationship i've
always dreamt of since when since you
were five
yeah i mean no it's no it's really nice
but it's like how how is someone who's
graduating from high school like i'm in
the relationship i've always dreamt of
like
i didn't know that
high school people dreamt
of
relationships in a way that they really
understood
maybe this person does see one of the
things when you do these questions is
it's very easy to superimpose where your
head was at it but it literally reads
like somebody who's like a 30 year old
it's like it's what i've always wanted
there's like a healthy amount of sex and
we don't get tired of each other it's
like that's this is a high school this
is someone who's just graduated you know
what i actually see your point they do
sound like they're 35. it's like
when did you dream of having this great
relationship all right well let's let's
let's let's continue here let's see what
we got here i could very well sing
[ __ ]
oh you think this is a [ __ ] well i
don't know it sounds nice i'm sorry
let's let's continue
well i'm very gullible you can get me i
could very well see myself spending the
rest of my life with this girl but at
the same times four years is a lot of
time i mean that's a [ __ ] marriage
right there everybody has that one
couple that wins best couple and they
got together their freshman sophomore
year and they just didn't know how to
break up so then they continue on and
continue on you know then you see him at
the 10-year reunion yeah we broke it off
when last week
and then they get on with their life
um i could very well see myself spending
the rest of my life with this girl but
at the same time four years is a lot of
time and a lot can change in that time
so i don't expect us i don't expect for
us to hook up again
the second we graduate however she's
come to be one of my closest friends and
i'd like to maintain that friendship and
she agrees i want to watch her life
unfold and watch her inevitably
inevitable success come alive
yeah these very mature people whether
we're romantically involved or not while
this will be a bit of a damper on the
beginning of college i know i'm going to
have a blast my roommate is one of my
best friends from high school he knows
how to deal with me and he'll kick my
ass to get back in shape if i start
getting mopey about this girl uh what's
your take on the situation any words of
advice or encouragement thanks in
advance
um
all right
i i would say uh
when you break up with somebody my thing
has always been when you break up with
them you gotta get away from them
because
as much as you have in a like this
mutual agreement or something like that
one of you
is gonna meet somebody first
and then it's just gonna be
rather than enjoying oh i met somebody
and seeing how that goes you're gonna
have to deal with the fact that you're
dragging somebody else through it and
they'll hear it in your voice you know
what are you doing nothing is there
somebody over there they're gonna figure
it out
and uh
if she finds out before you you know
find someone before you yeah you know
you can try to get her back i mean i
think i think
i think you guys should just go uh cold
turkey until you have your thanksgiving
break
personally maybe an email here email
there
uh but i think you guys should you know
if you're going to break up you got to
break up
i think
um
neil i'm actually i'm i'm still trying
to understand exactly what the question
is because honestly it sounds like from
this email
it sounds like you've got it figured out
perfectly to me
because we see we both agreed that it
wouldn't be healthy to try to maintain a
long-distance relationship so we're
spending these last few weeks of summer
together
uh yeah
i mean you're not going to be the only
person
in college and freshman year of college
who's left their boyfriend or girlfriend
behind that's a pretty
normal thing so
yeah spend your summer together it
sounds like a movie actually you know
spend the summer together and then you
both go off and
yeah thanksgiving break they'll probably
see each other and whatnot but i mean i
i honestly wouldn't put too much um
pressure on either one of you to try to
it sounds like you're both really
amazing lovely people and that's really
nice but yes you are going to meet other
people in college and the fact that
you're being
really realistic about it is um if you
had to guess i don't really have much to
say about it if you had to guess so
mature i kind of that's why i'm sort of
like stuck
all right you want to go to dead nancy
grandpa
nazi all right so yeah you guys see me
you got to figure it out yeah i don't
really there's not really much else to
say but what about my advice what i'm
saying he shouldn't stay in contact with
her
i don't i don't think that that's
possible i mean i don't think you should
try to continue a relationship like
let's try to like make it work you guys
have already said it's going to be too
hard but to be friends and things i mean
part of her blossoming will be her
blowing somebody else at some point i
don't want to be crass but i don't think
you don't want to be crass but you just
talked about well you don't want to see
those
blowing somebody listen there's a lot of
colors in a sunset okay there's a lot of
colors in the sunset you don't need to
see all of them blossoming coloring the
sunset you're really trying to make it
or sunrise sunrise blossoming sunset's
the end no i think they if if they're
gonna be friends that they're gonna
they're gonna text they're gonna email
they're gonna see each other's social
media activity like it's impossible not
to and someone may get jealous it's not
impossible not to you just don't look at
it
you cut it out
cut it out it doesn't sound like he
wants to cut it out because they really
enjoy each other i don't you know what
i'm doing i'm doing the exact thing that
i told you not to do i'm superimposing
my thoughts yeah like if we if we were
to god forbid if we were to break up or
whatever beat it you you would never
want to like
text me or like talk to me you just be
like of course of course i would but
like i i wouldn't
i wouldn't be involved in it because i
know
i know where that's going
right yeah
yeah
yeah i don't
but i don't think they should go cold
turkey yeah you'd meet some guy like
some guy named roger
roger
roy one of those are guys rick oh he's
got a car it's awesome
um all right
dead nazi grandpa dear billy blowhod
uh there's been a story going around in
the news here another philly story here
in philly for the past few weeks that i
want to hear your opinion on i'm writing
because i know you were a big world war
ii guy i was for like two months when i
was reading and then i [ __ ] gotten i
don't know i'm into [ __ ] quinoa yeah
and then you become obsessed with
something else that's what bill does he
gets really into something and he's like
obsessive about it and then he moves on
to the next thing which is why i'm a
comedian why i can't write scripts
because my mind works in bits i take a
little information and then i go oh
there's a spider on the wall you know
the funny thing is is that i give you a
hard time about that all the time and
i'm very similar to that
finally
okay and following this
okay uh i know you're a big world war ii
guy and follow and following this has
weirdly made me feel sympathy for an
ex-nazi so he's been following this
story and he feels sympathy for an
ex-nazi he says long story short there
was an 89 year old man who had served as
a guard in auswitch when he was 17. his
mother was born in the united states so
after the war he moved to the
philadelphia area he lived here under
his original name
um
and this is june i guess until june 2013
there was a word missing there when a
bavarian town passed a law allowing
ex-nazis to be excommunicated to germany
to face trial
he was eventually arrested and charged
with 158 counts of accessory to murder
there was a big argument about it the
guy just died in u.s prison this week i
got into an argument about this today
is it [ __ ] up for this guy to get
arrested 70 years later for something he
did as a teenager even if he is the
biggest [ __ ] on the planet i think the
philly cops have other [ __ ] to worry
about it's like that movie app pupil
that sounds like app people do you
remember that movie yeah except this guy
was uh
he wasn't
he was in a guard tower
where that other guy was like a rudolph
has more type of a guy
um i don't think it's [ __ ] up for you
to get arrested for something that you
did
yeah in your teenage years but if you
killed 158 people but this is the thing
he's a 17 this is the thing if he if he
came at it like this and saying listen
this guy was a teenager
all right
when this madman took over his country
he doesn't have a choice he has to join
the [ __ ] army
um and everybody is like well you know
you could say no i'm not doing it and
then it's like then you get your brains
blown out you can't just
go well [ __ ] it i'm out of here it's 17
where are you going to go
not only is your country completely at
war the entire continent is at war and i
think it's very easy to not be 17
in the middle of [ __ ] world war ii
and for you to sit there and go and like
you know what i would have done
i would have been an angel and i would
have done this this this and this and
this and it's just like
like i can have empathy
uh
for the situation that he was put into
but um
it's it's one of those things where it's
i mean
the thing what happened there i mean
they're prosecuting people i mean i
don't know do you think that the the 17
year old kid
i mean he's a [ __ ] kid i i the the
person or the people that would be very
concerned about having this person
arrested would be like
all right you know what's hilarious is
that me and mia just talked about this
subject
for like [ __ ] 15 minutes
and came to this great place as to why
you have to arrest this guy and the
[ __ ] batteries wore out
god damn it i know i told you i told you
this is just not uh this just ain't my
[ __ ] day
um
so all i can do is paraphrase oh god
what a [ __ ] buzz kill it's basically
kind of what what i left off saying it's
like you got to prosecute him
because he was part of a war crime
so you have to prosecute him
but i
you know i was
basically making the point that if this
kid in philly
who i i don't agree with the way he
seems to be defending him i'm defending
him the way i am i'm defending that 17
year old kid
in this way
that
everybody if he was to walk into a if
you anybody there was to walk you know
you guys were to walk into a bar and you
were to bring that up and you'd ask
people what they would do
what they would have done in that
situation everybody's gonna be captain
america everyone's gonna be like dude
you know what i would have done i would
go i would have [ __ ] shot hitler in
the face and i would have done no no
i've done that and all this type of [ __ ]
and it's just like
you know any it's very easy to be
[ __ ] sitting in a bar drinking a
[ __ ] rolling rock
and uh paint yourself out to be this
unbelievable hero and all this [ __ ] that
you would have done but like uh i think
unfortunately
this kid was born at the wrong [ __ ]
time i don't think that like i don't
know i mean i really don't think that
this this kid would you know
he would do you think that this kid was
just an evil kid and he was like psyched
to be up in that guard tower or is he
just i mean who knows like i'm not and
i'm not saying that i'm not saying that
i don't really know that it i don't
really think that it matters which was
my point i feel like this person's
sympathy is misplaced i'm not talking
about him i'm talking about me now oh
it's about you
yeah i'm telling you i'm talking about
my opinion
which is what that
you can't because he was 17 years old
chances are he wasn't
he didn't want to do it
and he was asked to do it i'm saying
it's 17 you're very impressionable
you can get talk that you can get brain
like a 30 30 uh
35 year old person 45 year old 55 year
old person
you know
at that point you you're
you know so much more about life
like people can't come up to you and
tell you like
it's very hard much very harder for for
uh much more difficult for somebody to
come up to you and try to convince you
of something that you know isn't true
that you know is not and you can spot
crazy from a [ __ ] mile away but what
i was talking about which of course got
lost was what
usually i don't know what it is about
people who are smart and people who are
like hey live and let live there because
of that intellect
they're also not
they don't choose violence
and unfortunately that's you need to
fight fire with fire where they're like
well violence doesn't solve anything
it's like violence would have solved
this
like when you were dealing with when
they were first starting to take over
and people were choosing
self-preservation rather than helping
out their neighbors
is what they should have gone out is
they should have gone out and like
i mean like this once again i'm doing
this what it could've should've [ __ ]
like oh dude you know what i would have
done you should have gone out there or
you should have organized the people on
your block
you know and if you had a jewish family
on your block going like look we're all
down with these are our friends they're
not taking them if they come down here
you know
we're [ __ ] taking them out
and if you started that movement and you
started taking them out before they took
everybody else out
you could actually stop it but the thing
is
is decent people regular people live and
let live people are essentially not
organized
and that's the only advantage
that they had
was they were walking around they were
organized
and then i think that people choose
the cowardly uh decision of
self-preservation
but i don't think self-preservation is
cowardly at 17. i think 17 i mean you
were a boy
you're not it's like that britney spears
not quite a woman you're not quite a man
there near and all of a sudden this this
[ __ ] event comes along and you get
swept up into it
so look if this guy was let me that's
what i'd say if this guy was 30 he was
in a guard tower [ __ ] him all right if
you're 17 in a guard tower you still got
to prosecute him but like i'm it's like
i'm going to sit there and be like dude
you know what i would have done to 17
when the entire continent was at war i
would have [ __ ] walked to africa and
just left it behind like i mean i don't
know what this kid's uh
i mean his his option was basically a
he he had to take a bullet in his own
head
or go up
there yeah i don't know
i don't know i'm out on this one
i think
i'm out
i mean i just don't feel like i don't
know i don't have anything
really to contribute anymore to that
question other than what i just said
about their sympathy being misplaced
yeah i can't seem to have a conversation
with you about what i'm saying you just
keep going back to this kid i'm not
saying that this kid i'm saying what i'm
saying and i'm i'm actually talking
about how a [ __ ] lunatic like hitler
comes into power he doesn't come into
power because he makes sense he comes
into power because
all these other people that don't think
he makes sense
they they choose self-preservation
okay he's not going after me i'm
protesting he's not going after me i'm
catholic he's not going after me i'm
straight and you and you and the fear of
watching your neighbors who you had a
[ __ ] cookout with and you hear them
screaming as they're getting dragged out
of the house and you know you should be
doing something but you don't because of
your own self-preservation i think it's
very easy for people to to hear this
story and be like oh that [ __ ] nazi
piece of [ __ ] blah blah blah these
people as adults would choose
self-preservation who would criticize
what this kid did when he was 17. that's
my point my point is not that that uh
um
that this is wrong that they're
prosecuting it's it's
but i also don't look at this dude who
when he was 17 who ended up in that that
situation like this was somebody who was
was
like clearly making decisions in his
life or even had control over the
direction of his life i mean there's a
reason why you can't drink till you're
21 it's because the level of immaturity
you have you think this kid can we at 17
has the [ __ ] maturity to be able to
handle what's going on walking down the
street and seeing people hanging from
you know by piano wire and that type of
thing i mean it's it's it's just another
ruined life because of of this [ __ ]
psycho
could you agree with that yeah i could
see that for sure all right this is way
too heavy a [ __ ] topic to be
discussing here so that's that's
basically the gist of what that's what
it is maybe it's just too it maybe it's
just too early it's too heavy i don't
know maybe i'm still asleep
and i can't quite get into it how much
uh hum
after what meal during the day can you
discuss uh for me former guard tower uh
nazi guard tower kids more of an after
lunch conversation i think okay
all right well that's the podcast for
this week
jesus christ the levels just went up
sorry about that that's the podcast for
this week thank you for everybody for
listening thank you for writing in uh
thank you to the great tony v for giving
me that great intro up in uh
uh up in montreal thank you to the
montreal comedy festival everybody who
came out
and
uh
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk
to you next week
you